[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález se cumplen 15
años desde que una mujer hija de un
pastor luterano y una maestra sin hijos
casada en segundas nupcias que creció en
la desaparecida alemania comunista y con
una corta pero muy destacada carrera
política llegó de manera casi inesperada
al cargo de canciller federal de
alemania muchos cuestionaron su
capacidad para gobernar para liderar
confrontar defender posiciones y para
ganar consensos
angela dorothea kashna o mejor conocido
como angela merkel por el apellido de su
primer esposo ya tiene un lugar
garantizado en las páginas de historia
de la historia política de alemania por
ser la primera mujer en llegar al cargo
de canciller federal en ser la canciller
más votada de la historia y también en
ser la más joven en llegar a ese cargo
político en alemania pero cuál es el
balance de su gobierno al frente del
llamado motor económico de europa y
también pues por supuesto de uno de los
países más importantes de la acción
internacional cuáles son los aciertos
cuáles son las deudas pendientes
en términos políticos que tiene angela
merkel quien en sus inicios políticos
era conocida simplemente como la
muchacha o simplemente angie mientras
que de este lado del atlántico es
conocida como la dama fuerte de alemania
la canciller de hierro o simplemente la
merkel hoy en el debate de france 24
hablamos de los 15 años de angela merkel
en el poder en alemania para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a cristina
mendoza viva ella es periodista y
coautora del libro angela merkel la
física del poder ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de berlín la capital alemana en
würzburgo en el estado de baviera en el
sur de alemania se encuentra franco
delle donne él es analista internacional
también es doctor en comunicación y
también se conecta desde la capital
alemana thomas sparrow él es periodista
analista internacional también autor de
varios libros y es una cara conocida en
la cadena es el corresponsal de france
24 en alemania les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar sus preguntas y sus
comentarios en las redes sociales
en recuerdo estamos en facebook y
también nos encuentran en instagram y en
twitter como france24
del piso sant y luego mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 pues comenzamos y quiero comenzar
por conocer primero opiniones y
posiciones al respecto y comienzo
entonces con cristina
en la ciudad de berlín christina cuál es
el balance que usted hace de estos 15
años de angela merkel en el poder en
alemania
bueno sin duda es una mujer que ha
logrado muchas cosas de una forma
pragmática no hay que olvidar que ella
ha cambiado su política y ha renacido en
muchos en muchas instancias y sobre todo
es una gran gestora de crisis y con cada
crisis que vive y que gestiona se crece
entonces en este caso mi balance es
positivo pero falta ver todavía en este
año en este último año que le queda que
va a suceder porque todavía está por
verse cuál va a ser su legado
francos delle donne en el sur de
alemania en el estado de baviera cuál es
su opinión al respecto al balance de
gestión
coincido en en el calificativo que
utilizaba cristina recién ella es una
canciller que se ocupó de muchas crisis
no fue solamente la de la pandemia ni
tampoco la de los refugiados de hace
unos años sino que hubo varias tal vez
después ampliamos sobre el tema pero
creo que en ese punto ella ha sabido
manejar situaciones muy complicadas
situaciones que tal vez a otros líderes
les hubiese costado el cargo y ella lo
pudo llevar adelante pese a que como
decías en la presentación las
expectativas no eran altas y tal vez esa
es la ventaja al no levantar tantas
expectativas pudo hacerse cargo de esas
situaciones tan complicadas y salir
airosos adelante hay cuestiones
pendientes pero creo que en líneas
generales le dejara mucho más alemania-
de lo que se esperaba al principio vamos
a retomar más adelante la conexión con
tomás es para nuestro corresponsal en la
ciudad de berlín también para conocer
cuál es el balance que él hace de angela
merkel en su gestión como canciller
christina como lo decíamos al principio
ya ustedes han tocado algunos puntos al
respecto era una política angela merkel
poco conocida en la escena
de la alemania reunificada hasta que
llegó allí avon y logró alcanzar algunos
primeros cargos como ministro en dos
carteras diferentes y poco a poco se
empezó a dar a conocer pero eran muy
pocos los que daban votos por ella
cuando llegó a la cancillería como logro
ella construir ese liderazgo y ese
consenso que le ha llevado a mantenerse
en el poder durante 15 años
yo destacaría varias de sus cualidades y
en este caso también fórmulas del éxito
y una de ellas es que gracias a que
científica es capaz de ver todos los
problemas o las situaciones con un
proceso que es cambiante y que y que no
tiene fin y en este caso en los temas en
los que ella no era versada recordemos
que ella asumió el poder en el 22 de
noviembre del 2005 por ejemplo le tocó
en 2006 el mundial de fútbol y ya no era
versada en el mundial el fútbol le
gustaba mucho el fútbol pero no era tan
versada y ella lo que hace con todos los
temas los que no tiene tanta información
es reunirse de un grupo de expertos
coteja a todas las variables define
diferentes escenarios y hasta que no
estás 100% segura sobre el camino que
quiere seguir en ese caso
no toma una decisión algunos algunos
expertos analistas también definen esto
como la política de pasos cortos en los
que ella no te ella no tendría una
visión a largo plazo
de esta posición porque me parece que de
todas maneras el devenir mundial
iniciando también con la crisis
financiera y del euro en 2007 posterior
angela merkel ha tocado sortear todas
estas crisis y al mismo tiempo a
aprender y a lograr sobrellevó
sobrepasar digamos esa esa subestimación
que le ponían muchos porque porque es
mujer porque por la primera mujer
canciller en alemania y porque no tenía
tanta trascendencia en la política como
como otros otros personajes no entonces
en este caso yo creo que esos son varias
cosas uno es ser científica y al mismo
tiempo es el pragmatismo que le permite
a ella variar y mirar también sus
políticas podemos recordar por ejemplo
fukushima al desastre fukushima el 2010
cuando ella decidió cambiar la política
energética alemana aunque en la cdu en
la unión cristianodemócrata a su partido
no estuvieron de acuerdo y ahí empezaron
también a costarle pues diferentes en
diferentes posiciones pero yo creo que
ese es el manejo científico y el
pragmatismo que lo ha logrado
ocultar a una lideresa mundial bueno
entonces para lograr ese liderazgo
pragmatismo y su formación como
científica es la opinión de cristina
franco cuál es su opinión al respecto
pero es un un liderazgo que lleva
bastante tiempo en el poder ella además
de ser la canciller es la jefa del
partido cristianodemócrata desde el año
2000 son muchos años al frente del
partido bueno ahora cambio hace un año
dejó de serlo pero fueron muchos años al
frente del partido y antes de eso ella
aprendió mucho de lo que es de alguna
manera su padrino político
helmut kohl el canciller alemán de los
80 y los 90 y en ese sentido ella al
incorporarse a esa cartel a cartera
aprende mucho de cómo funciona la
política desde mi punto de vista pero
luego como bien marca cristina e
implementa su propia forma de liderar su
propia forma de líder al que tal vez
tiene que ver con su formación y también
yo creo que tiene que ver con una forma
de liderazgo femenino que es diferente a
lo que hacen los hombres que tal vez se
imponen de diferentes maneras ella ha
sido capaz de construir su poder de una
forma mucho más progresiva digamos a lo
largo del tiempo y ella ha estado
también
en el momento justo en el lugar indicado
por ejemplo cuando en el año 2000 ella
toma el liderazgo del partido en
realidad ella no era la que estaba
señalada para hacerlo iba a ser otra
persona que bueno no viene al caso
después terminan siendo ministro
economía de jan o wolfgang schaeuble
pero ella en ese momento tiene esa
ventaja de poder imponerse y de tomar
decisiones difíciles por ejemplo quien
fuera su padrino político helmut kohl
a principios de los 2000 tienen una
situación que sale a la luz a una
situación de corrupción que nunca estuvo
muy muy clara del todo pero digamos que
lo pone a su partido a una situación
difícil y ella como presidenta del
partido pese a que él era su padrino
político helmut kohl ella dijo esto
quiso es el músculo está mal yo no voy a
apoyar esto y no voy a permitir que mi
partido tenga que apoyar esto por algún
tipo de lealtad histórica etcétera y no
tuvo miedo de poner digamos de separarse
digamos de alejarse de la figura de
helmut kohl no y eso le valió a ella
sumar enemigos pero también sumar una
personalidad que se fue viendo a lo
largo del tiempo a la hora de tomar
decisiones difíciles incluso cuando
tenía que cambiar de opinión como el
ejemplo de fukushima que es clarísimo
para poder construir esa autoridad y hoy
en día bueno termina siendo una no
solamente una de las líderes más
importantes de alemania sino en el
escenario mundial es una de las personas
también más respetadas y el franco
cristian hago la ronda a la inversa
continuó entonces con francos usted
habla de una forma de liderar particular
es mujer ya lo habíamos dicho es una
mujer muy tímida también muy sencilla en
su forma de vestirse de presentarse de
muy pocas palabras muy puntuales el
grano cuando tiene que dirigirse a los
medios de comunicación y tiene que dar a
conocer algún tipo de mensaje a los
alemanes pero me interesa saber cuál era
la coyuntura que había en alemania en el
momento en el que ella llega al poder
para que precisamente sea angela merkel
a que llegue al poder que le abren las
puertas a una mujer que como lo decíamos
tiene
con recorrido en el mundo de la política
alemana frente a personalidades que
llevaban mucho tiempo y fuera de eso
también una persona que venía del este
se convierte en la primera persona
nacida en la alemania oriental que llega
al cargo de la cancillería y llega a un
cargo destacado en esta alemania
reunificada
sí esa es una cuestión bastante
importante el tema de que ellas del este
recordemos que alemania se termina de
reunificar en el año 90 justo este año
se cumplen los 30 años de la
reunificación y claramente que alguien
llegue del este alguien llega a esos
niveles de poder es muy raro en alemania
está bastante mal repartido en ese
sentido los lugares de poder entre el
este y el oeste pero está esa es una
discusión más compleja y más larga que
dar
lo que me parece importante de lo que
acabas de mencionar cuando en el 2005
ella termina ganando la elección y bueno
termina siendo la canciller de ese nuevo
gobierno la situación es muy complicada
es decir en su propio partido no tenía
la confianza total y por fuera solo que
lo que después serían sus socios de
coalición que sería el partido
socialdemócrata
tampoco confiaban en ella todos creían
que iba a ser un gobierno de transición
que iba a durar muy poco que de alguna
manera iba a reemplazar a asier que era
el anterior canciller socialdemócrata
que bueno tenía una situación bastante
complicada en ese momento que bueno
había tomado determinadas decisiones y
generado mucho descontento
sectores de la población entonces ángela
angela merkel llega justo en ese momento
y tiene que hacerse cargo de un gobierno
con una votación que había salido muy
reñida el resultado final era una
diferencia de décimas entre su partido y
la socialdemocracia y lo que terminan
decidiendo es hacer algo histórico que
se había hecho una sola vez en hasta ese
momento en alemania que eres que era
construir una gran coalición que se le
llama gran coalición a un gobierno
formado por los dos partidos
mayoritarios es decir los dos partidos
de alguna manera siempre compitieron por
el poder y deciden juntarse para bueno
brindar determinadas soluciones generar
determinadas reformas que se ve que se
tenían que hacer y para eso se
necesitaban consensos amplios y ellos se
pone al frente de esa gran coalición es
decir ella tenía que de alguna manera
ser la líder de los pesos pesados más
importantes de alemania una persona en
la que poca gente como decía cristina
antes tenía esa confianza que no había
muchas expectativas algunos hasta los
solas subestimaban y en ese sentido ella
tuvo que hacerse fuerte en ese contexto
y
y la verdad es que lo ha logrado no con
su estilo como decíamos antes con sus
formas algunas decisiones que después
tuvieron que cambiar como el caso de
fukushima pero también podemos mencionar
el tema de los refugiados en algún punto
y en ese sentido ha logrado construir
este liderazgo que hoy la lleva a hacer
la política mejor bala después de 15
años sigue siendo la política mejor
valorada del país
christina su opinión que el legado tiene
angela merkel 15 años al frente alemania
siendo una mujer esto representativo sin
duda alguna para la política alemana
pero no solo para la política alemana
sino yo diría también mundial no
olvidemos una encuesta de naciones
unidas sólo el 7% de todos los líderes
mundiales son mujeres estamos hablando
de 10 de 10 mujeres de 152 líderes
mundiales gentes de gobierno presidentes
pero yo antes antes de antes de hablar
del legado coincido con franco en que en
que la llegada de angela merkel en el
2005 también se debió a diferentes
casualidades porque en realidad ella
quería optar por x como candidata a la
cancillería mucho antes pero por
rencillas y también poderes masculinos
en su partido no pudo y en el 2005
cuando ella llegó a la cancillería ella
ella enfrentaba a un país que tenía un
problema económico alemán ya se le que
se le denominaba en ese entonces el
hombre enfermo o el paciente alemán y
gracias a las reformas que hizo el
gobierno anterior y con eso
con el mundial de fútbol que mostró
también una cara distinta de alemania y
todas las diferentes facetas y visitas
que hizo angela merkel a nivel
internacional
y competir también irrumpir como dijo la
revista forbes en 2006 cuando se le
otorgó el título de la mujer más
poderosa del mundo como irrumpir en un
lugar de sólo hombres y empezar a regir
también el destino del país más poderoso
económicamente también hablando de
europa ahora sobre su legado en mucho se
ha dicho y más ahora que alemania tiene
la presidencia y ocupa la presidencia de
la unión europea este semestre y termina
ahorita en diciembre es que para angela
merkel el legado que ella quisiera dejar
es es la unión europea el proyecto
europeo común como una integración unida
es decir que los países los miembros los
27 miembros de la unión europea sigan
unidos y sean un bloque lo
suficientemente fuerte para actuar en la
geopolítica internacional en este
sentido todavía falta
falta por ver qué pasa porque él hay que
decir que también la pandemia en el
coronavirus truncó muchas de las de las
propuestas que ya llevaba para
la presidencia de la unión europea y a
raíz de esto también ha cambiado mucho
dentro del bloque ella ella ya cruzó
líneas rojas de endeudamiento para en
términos de solidaridad ayudar a los
países que más han sufrido por la
pandemia
entonces el legado yo creo que estaba
también por verse porque todavía le
falta un año y en estas circunstancias
también es un poco difícil ver qué es lo
que va a pasar pero yo diría que uno de
sus grandes proyectos es ese es que el
bloque europeo se mantenga unido fuerte
y no no se deje a mirar por las olas
crisis cristina y el legado que puede
dejar ella como mujer en la escena
política
usted lo lleva un poco más allá alemania
lo lleva también al al alcohol al resto
de la unión europea cuál puede ser el
legado de ella pero como mujer política
claro nosotros en nuestro libro angela
merkel a física del poder tenemos un
anexo que cuenta que analiza si angela
merkel es feminista o no y en este caso
obviamente decimos que no va por varias
razones pero pero la cuestión es que
ella empodera de alguna manera es un
referente para muchas mujeres no
solamente en alemania hay muchas chicas
en alemania que no han conocido otro
otro jefe de gobierno que no sea mujer
que es angela merkel pero también es
llegar como es a esa paridad y esa
igualdad de la que habla angela merkel
más que de feminismo en el en cargos
relevantes de poder y ella también dijo
en una entrevista que una sola
golondrina no hace verano y que y que de
alguna manera está en todos nosotros
lograr que lograr que las mujeres tengan
tengan unos cargos mucho más relevantes
en todo sentido yo creo que yo creo que
más que más que como feminismo o como
mujer propiamente está en la en la
cuestión de la igualdad en la igualdad
de oportunidades para todos
y en este caso como mujer también
profesional que logró sobrepasar todas
estas estas cuestiones de lo que la
subestimaban lo que pensaban que era
demasiado sensible o no iba a poder con
estos juegos juegos de poder que en
realidad ella ella ella estreno
completamente y con él cambió
completamente la percepción del mundo
político en alemania y empezó a ser
percibida como una mujer determinada a
llevar liderazgo ya sacar alemania
adelante sobre todo esta crisis
económica en la que ella recibió el país
en ese momento quiero que sigamos
haciendo balance franco y en estos 15
años ha habido varios aciertos y varios
desaciertos en estas políticas que haya
llevado adelante como todos los
políticos y líderes a nivel
internacional pues han sido criticados o
han sido también alabados por algunas de
las decisiones que han tomado cuál
quiere usted que son esos aciertos y
esos desaciertos y aquí vamos entonces
armando con christina el rompecabezas
entre ustedes dos de es el listado de
de balance de estos 15 años
bueno empiezo yo empiece a que si
adelante francos
bueno a ver ahí hay varias es muy largo
no son 15 años podríamos estar anoche no
ablandaron pero pero los puntos
principales que yo te les traigo algunos
en la mesa y si usted los van
organizando como porque ustedes son los
que conocen más del tema migración
economía la pandemia la política europea
y política exterior y yo añadiría y un
poco política al otro lado del atlántico
en la relación con eeuu tal vez
bueno a ver hay una cosa que puede que
digamos con lo que puedo empresa empezar
que me gustaría crear cuando me gustaba
agregar cuando estaba hablando christina
antes que tiene que ver con el legado no
y
creo que se relaciona con el balance
también por eso me parece importante
ella lo que transmite en esta época de
donde crece mucho la polarización no
solamente en alemania sino en muchos
lugares de europa y del mundo una idea
más centrista no una idea de construir
el consenso de elaborar políticas a
partir de los pactos a partir de
dialogar a partir de de alguna manera
establecer puntos en común ente en
diferentes fuerzas que puedan pensar
diferente y creo que ese es un elemento
muy importante y lo tomaría como si bien
es algo simbólico como un elemento muy
importante de lo que nos deja merkel y
de como ella como ejemplo de como ella
fue llevando adelante diferentes
decisiones pero más allá de eso es
cierto que una una crítica bastante
grande tiene que ver con tal vez no
manejado el tema de los refugiados en el
2005 de una manera un poco más un poco
más veloz y se quiere casi en
contraposición con lo que se con lo que
comentaba a christina digamos de tomar
decisiones de manera tal vez un poco más
lenta evaluando muchas variables
en ese sentido muchos esperaban que se
reacciona rápido y eso le valió o le dio
una oportunidad a otros partidos tal vez
incluso más en posiciones más
extremistas de tener lugar en la agenda
de discutir sobre el tema de decir que
el gobierno no tiene una política de
migración etcétera y en ese sentido tal
vez generó el crecimiento de un partido
bastante peligroso en términos de lo que
significa que una derecha radical tenga
el peso que tiene ahora en alemania pero
contrariamente en el caso de la pandemia
al menos en la primera fase hasta el
verano que terminó ahora en el norte del
mundo de alguna manera ella pudo manejar
las cosas
de una forma bastante eficiente
transmitiendo ideas que el resto de los
líderes tal vez no podían transmitir
utilizando otros marcos comunicacionales
por ejemplo en vez de apelar al tema de
la guerra y de que hay que vencer al
virus se habló siempre de un desafío que
juntos tenemos que superar y esos son
muchos elementos que marcan su liderazgo
y que marcan también las una uno de los
puntos digamos que ha llevado adelante
con éxito en ese sentido creo que ahí se
pueden ver dos dos crisis que tuvo que
superar de diferente manera y que tal
vez generaron más o menos críticas en
ese sentido pero clave de jara cristina
que también cristina al fin es otro lado
la voy a interrumpir y voy a abrir aquí
un espacio para darle la palabra a tomás
que ya restablecimos la comunicación con
él y lo quiero incorporar aquí al debate
ya solucionamos todo el tema técnico
tomás bienvenido al debate de france 24
y estamos haciendo aquí con con nuestros
dos invitados un listado de estos
aciertos y desaciertos que ha tenido la
política angela merkel en tanto política
exterior como política para alemania
para la unión europea
y cuál es su opinión al respecto
uno de los grandes problemas que ha
tenido la canciller alemana angela
merkel o por lo menos según sus críticos
es una especie de falta de visión o sea
si bien hay hay quienes consideran que
ella ha sido muy buena en el manejo de
crisis a lo que ya franco y christina
muy bien mencionaban también a quienes
aseguran que ella le falta como esa
visión de largo plazo que muchos
cancilleres alemanes y muchos líderes de
otros países han presentado en su
momento y más bien dicen que es una
persona que reacciona muy bien a las
crisis y a los problemas que se vayan
apareciendo que vaya teniendo enfrente y
como ya digo también cristina
reuniéndose de un grupo de expertos que
la asesora en todo momento y usa lo que
se ha podido ver en muchos temas en
alemania y yo creo que cuando miren en
unos 10 ó 15 años cuál es el legado de
la canciller alemana angela merkel van a
revisar por supuesto todos esos temas de
crisis o sea puntos altos para ella que
la hacen una política muy popular en
alemania de hecho franco también ya
aseguraba que angela merkel sigue siendo
hoy la política alemana más popular pero
también van a mirar esos proyectos de
a largo plazo que de pronto ella no pudo
poner adelante el tema por ejemplo
climático es uno en el que ella si bien
ha intentado mucho también hay quienes
critican que alemania no ha podido
cumplir sus metas climáticas entonces
son va a ser un legado de momentos muy
altos pero también de momentos muy
problemáticos y creo que uno de los
momentos problemáticos y una de las
cosas que también van a mirar cuando
miren el legado de angela merkel es que
fue durante su gobierno durante sus 15
años que también se pudo dar el
surgimiento de la extrema derecha en
alemania qué tiene que ver también con
el hecho de que ella movió a su partido
hacia él hacia el centro del espectro
político algo que la benefició a ella
pero que muchos consideran que puso en
riesgo también a su propio partido
coincidido también con franco y con y
con tomás en que en que hay varias
deudas pendientes pero yo empezaría
primero con los foros aciertos porque me
gustaría empezar por por por el más
reciente y es el manejo la gestión de la
crisis de coronavirus
de todas maneras ya en esta segunda ola
que se está viviendo aquí en europa
también hemos visto ayer lo vimos muchas
manifestaciones una manifestación
multitudinaria ante la puerta de
brandeburgo del eje de poder el centro
de poder aquí donde hay muchas personas
que están descontentas con las
restricciones que se están llevando a
cabo aquí en alemania para combatir y
luchar contra contra el coronavirus otro
acierto me parece a mí la política
económica debe de forjar también esta es
el país como lalo como locomotora como
dicen de europa y también el enfoque que
ha puesto la canciller angela merkel en
la política en ámbitos multilaterales
sobre las deudas pendientes yo hablaría
también de cuando angela mente se vaya
la polarización en alemania va a estar
en grados bastante altos no solamente
por su decisión de dejar ingresar a más
de un millón de refugiados en el 2015
sino también esa deuda pendiente que
queda de cómo ha sido la integración de
todos estos refugiados en alemania y que
ha pasado por ejemplo en términos
también de investigación contra contra
las las actividades terroristas que
tanto amenazan también a esta parte del
mundo islamistas y otra deuda en
términos de medio ambiente como ya lo
mencionaba también también tomás la
política energética que si bien ella
decidió hacer un viraje todavía no se ha
podido culminar en términos de pasar a
las energías renovables como estaba
pensado inicialmente en el 2020 2030
estas son algunas de las deudas que
quedan pendientes a mí me llama la
atención que ustedes ponen sobre la mesa
un término y es la falta de visión
pero la perspectiva que tal vez tenemos
desde este lado del atlántico y desde
américa latina es que alemania recuperó
cierto posicionamiento internacional
bajo este gobierno de merkel y ha
asumido un liderazgo que puede ser de
pronto un poco un liderazgo compartido
con francia a nivel de la unión europea
cuál es la opinión que ustedes tienen al
respecto porque esto de la falta de
visión pues pensaría uno que tal vez lo
que angela merkel podría pensar al
inicio de su gobierno era precisamente
catapultar a alemania otra vez a
recuperar ese posicionamiento
internacional entonces como lo ven
ustedes y comienzo por tomás
uno de los problemas en alemania es ese
tema del liderazgo alemán ya obviamente
por su historia tiene cierto reacio a
asumir posiciones de liderazgo y de ahí
que alemania se considere como un país
firmemente anclado en la unión europea
algo que por cierto la canciller angela
merkel ha reiterado en muchísimos de sus
discursos en particular en sus discursos
ante el parlamento aquí alemán cuando
asegura que alemania solamente le va a
ir bien si a europa le va bien eso
quiere decir que en otras palabras
angela merkel considera que el liderazgo
de alemania solamente puede ser
compartido ya christina mencionaba todo
el tema del multilateralismo que es una
de las banderas primordiales de alemania
en temas de política exterior y por
cierto también una de las razones por
las cuales la canciller angela merkel
choco tan fuertemente con el actual
presidente de eeuu donald trump entonces
cuando uno mira el liderazgo de alemania
abajo angloamérica el uno claramente
puede explicar y entender que alemania
ha ganado peso a nivel internacional es
un peso que principalmente es económico
y que va de la mano también con esa
influencia política aunque hay quienes
aseguran que alemania debería tener
más peso por ejemplo militar es algo que
por ejemplo eeuu siempre ha criticado en
los últimos años no solamente bajo
nuestro amp sino también en el gobierno
de barack obama pero es el liderazgo
compartido es uno de los elementos
esenciales para entender la política
exterior de alemania y la política
exterior de alemania bajo angela merkel
por un lado es hay quienes consideran
que el multilateralismo es sin duda una
fortaleza por el otro lado de quienes
consideran que alemania debería hacer
mucho más debería tener un rol mucho más
importante dado su peso económico en el
continente y dado también el peso
político que va adquiriendo el franco su
opinión muy puntual que ya me quedan
pocos minutos no me parece muy muy
interesante lo que cuenta
tomás coincido en el hecho de pensar que
alemania recordemos que es soberana
desde hace muy poco tiempo cuando sea la
reunificación efectivamente ahí tiene
esa posibilidad digamos y en ese sentido
muchos países no estaban y algunos ni
siquiera están todavía interesados en
alemania
la superpotencia ni mucho menos y creo
que tampoco está en las intenciones ni
de alemania general ni de merkel lo que
yo me pregunto es efectivamente qué va a
pasar después de estos 15 años es decir
este este tipo de liderazgo de esta
forma de manejar la cuestión pública tal
vez sin un horizonte sin un norte sin
una visión como pudieron tener otros
cancilleres como fue helmut kohl con la
reunificación como fue billy brandt con
la política del este tal vez a merkel
eso eso le falte o eso no no es parte de
lo más primordial pero sí está claro que
después cuando cuando ella se retire no
tenemos claro cuál va a ser el rol de
alemania y los liderazgos que se
preparan para sucederla tienen visiones
bastante diferentes con lo cual vamos a
ver una situación de una situación
bisagra diría yo en alemania que bueno
pronto conoceremos para el cierre de
esta ronda cristina adelante
coincido con un franco también que es
una situación bastante pues es de
incertidumbre realmente lo que va a
pasar una vez aunque la mercantes del
poder porque no durante todo todos todos
los cuatro mandatos nunca se le ha visto
algún sucesor o sucesora que realmente
digamos le llega le llegue a su talla no
entonces en este caso con todas las
políticas con peleas políticas también
el interior de su partido falta ver qué
va a pasar también si va a crecer más
también la aeb del partido
ultraderechista y en esta cuestión yo
creo que la falta de visión también
también viene porque le critican a
merkel que ella en realidad
gobierna revisando las encuestas de
opinión y en este caso de alguna manera
esto también forja lo que ya había dicho
de una política de pequeños pasos
resolviendo todos los problemas y las
circunstancias que sean vienen en cada
momento pero también es cierto que como
científica ella sí ha visto
y sopesado todas las diferentes
variables para para un fin quizá ese fin
es más inmediato que a largo plazo pero
pero también ahora
con las diferentes crisis que le ha
tocado vivir también ha cambiado y ha
variado también su forma de hacer
política y también y también sus
intereses me queda me queda poco más de
un minuto y medio del programa tomás
para la conclusión que seguirá para
angela merkel después deja la
cancillería
probablemente su retiro hay quienes aquí
esperan que pueda escribir también un
libro un libro que por cierto podría ser
muy interesante pero ella claramente
indicó que no tiene ninguna intención de
asumir ningún cargo político es decir
que muy probablemente ella se va a
retirar y va a dejar que otros en
alemania asuman las riendas o sea no va
a ser una canciller incómoda no creo que
eso vaya a ser el caso de ang la mente
franco rápidamente 30 segundos para su
conclusión en donde la mente es el lugar
si algunos hablan del lugar en europa
pero como dice tomás es una mujer que
trabajó mucho es una mujer que se la ve
en las entrevistas necesito un descanso
y creo que ese descanso se lo va a tomar
muy en serio
christina usted que conoce profundamente
angela merkel después de escribir este
libro cuál es su opinión algunos dicen
que se va a dedicar a la docencia a
visitar las diferentes 17 o más
universidades que le han otorgado el
honoris causa alrededor del mundo y
también seguir los pasos de alexander
con humboldt como dijo cuando inició su
ruta su primer viaje
américa latina' pues si tienen ustedes
la opinión de nuestros tres invitados
del programa de hoy muchas gracias a los
tres por haber estado aquí en el debate
france24 haber compartido con nosotros
sus puntos de vista en torno a este tema
ustedes muchas gracias también por haber
dejado sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales los invito
para que sigan escribiendo y dejando sus
comentarios a través de ellas gracias
por su sintonía siga con france24
[Música]